esther tengo problemas que pasó en el
comelón se comió los números de mi
cuadrícula ja ja ja ja ja qué buenos
estaban esos números
mejor me voy de aquí antes de meterme en
algún problema en este el que voy a
hacer todo estable además trabajar
juntas para encontrar los números que
faltan ritual creo tratando se están
viendo este vídeo nos pueden ayudar
amigos los invito a pasar el vídeo y
traten de descubrir las números que
faltan ok
asumo que nuestros amigos ya lo hicieron
pero qué piensas de esto este déjame ver
podemos usar las números que están antes
del número que falta para encontrarlo
aceite vamos a ver aquí estar 4
esto tiene sentido y como encontramos
este y vamos a ver si podemos escoger el
canon a los errores pues al parecer tal
vez tenemos que dejar a nuestros amigos
que piensen en este número primero buena
idea creo que nuestros amigos ya lo
hicieron y tú cuál número que es que
sigue del 13 de harvard para hacer cap
abrazador claro y esto funciona bien
porque el 14 va antes del 15 está
exactamente okey mira este todo está
completo hasta aquí pero como sabemos
qué número va aquí esther
tal vez podemos usar los números que
están después del número que falta que
tenemos el 37 38 y el 39 creo que aquí
va el 36 y el 36 antes del 37 claro eso
está muy bien y cuál será el número que
va justo aquí abajo no quiere dejarme
ver creo que podemos contar de una
manera diferente vamos a contar de
arriba a abajo cuál y cómo vas a hacer
eso bueno va a empezar con el número
hacer los gordos y se vaya abajo al 26
más abajo al 30 al 6 creo que veo un
patrón aquí todos estos números tienen
un 6 exactamente así que creo que el
número que falta es el 4 en parece claro
que sí eso tiene sentido aquí tenemos el
26 luego 36 y aquí tenemos los 40s así
que sigue el 46
exactamente eso está padrísimo y cuáles
números faltan aquí abajo tal vez
nuestros amigos pausa en el vídeo y
tratan de encontrar los números que
faltan aquí eso estaría muy bien
ok como encontramos estos estén bueno
para encontrar estos números vamos a ver
cuáles números están antes y después
hace que aquí tenemos 81 80 los 83 84 y
eso está muy bien porque estamos en los
80s y así como tenemos aquí 1234 aquí
tenemos 81 82 83 84 exactamente pues
después del 84 señor el 85 y sabemos eso
porque el 5 siguió después del 4 así que
85 sigue después de 84
wow y este seguramente es 86 esto es
emocionante mirar todo o no aquí viene
bien el comerlo en otra vez guau veo más
números me está dando hambre